ok on va sortir la voix off parce que
s'il ya un moment où il faut sortir une
voix off c'est maintenant c'est dans
cette vidéo la maintenant parce que
c'est vraiment important
là c'est ma vidéo des 3000 abonnés
c'était ya plus de deux ans ça fait une
éternité j'ai l'impression est depuis
des vidéos j'en ai enchaîné j'en ai
enchaîné ufologues ya eu des plus tôt il
ya eu des rencontres avec des gens il ya
eu plein de vidéastes que j'ai
rencontrés que j'ai eu l'honneur de
rencontrer avec qui j'ai pu travailler
il ya eu tellement de choses qui se sont
passées tellement de personnes
rencontrées par le biais des
commentaires par le biais des réseaux
sociaux c'est juste extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire jusqu'au point où bas
j'étais pas vidéaste à la base c'était
pas mon métier et ça l'est devenu
et vous l'avez vu en fait avec
l'évolution de cette chaîne vous m'avez
vu devenir vidéaste vous m'avez vu en
faire mon métier ça je trouve ça assez
extraordinaire et c'est celle youtube
qui m'a indirectement amener tout ça
c'est c'est vous au final qui m'avaient
amené tout ça aussi et quand je regarde
ces vidéos ça me fait vraiment quelque
chose d'assez particulier parce que
parce que voilà je vois tout chemin
parcouru je vois une vie qui a
totalement basculé et totalement changé
pour du positif
franchement et que du bon et cette vidéo
là elle est très importante pour moi
parce que c'est une façon de vous
montrer tout ça et vous remercier vous
dire merci je vais vous dire beaucoup
merci
dans cette vidéo vous allez voir
pourquoi un petit peu je vais essayer de
faire ça le jeu peut et devrait
remercier marie aussi parce que l'air de
rien ma vie est là elle a changé mais
celle de marie aussi marie dont vous
pouvez voir le travail dans toutes les
dernières vidéos elle fait beaucoup de
bureaux sur la chaîne elle fait et dans
le monde choses et m supporter ce qui
est déjà beaucoup
ce qui est déjà assez énorme ça me
paraissait important d'en parler aussi
puis vous êtes 50000 bon 150000 c'est
juste dingue c'est un stade de foot
immense et c'est dix fois le zénith de
pau 1 là où j'habite c'est c'est presque
la population de ma ville voilà c'est un
nombre qui est qui qui qui fou qui est
totalement fou j'arrive pas du tout en
fait à visualiser combien ça fait
cinquante mille mais en tout cas il ya
un truc que je visualise très très bien
c'est la façon dont je vais dans cette
vidéo vous dire merci
[Musique]
alors comment vous dire merci
comment vous dire merci je me suis posé
la question vraiment savoir comment
j'allais pouvoir faire quelque chose qui
serait à la hauteur de tout ça et je me
suis dit que la meilleure façon de vous
remercier c'était de vous faire gagner
des trucs c'était vous offrir des
cadeaux comme le cadeau que vous fait de
vous abonner à ma chaîne c'est juste
hyper cool alors je suis allé à la pêche
un petit peu pour pouvoir vous offrir
des trucs et vous allez voir il y en a
pour environ 2500 euros de lots et je
voulais surtout pas que ce soit des
récompenses qu'ils soient liés au hasard
d'eau qu'il n'y a pas de abonne toi
laisse un commentaire suis moi sur
instagram est à 50 potes
voilà dans sa devrait y avoir quelque
chose à faire de votre part même si vous
pouvez vous abonner et la chaîne bien
entendu et que vous pouvez aussi me film
sur instagram un pas de souci ça fait
toujours plaisir et c'est toujours cool
mais avant de vous dire ce que vous
allez devoir faire je vais vous dire un
petit peu quels seront les lots il y
aura sept gagnants
les 7e 6e et 5e gagnerons mais pâques de
près 7 et de lutte voilà c'est cadeau
c'est pour cela c'est un petit cadeau
mais un cadeau sympathique ce qui arrive
en 4ème et 3ème gagnant 1 an
d'abonnement à arcalis avons environ 200
balade année c'est toutes les musiques
que j'utilise ce soit pour mes clients
que ce soit pour youtube il ya les
effets aussi sonore qui sont plus
maintenant
donc c'est musique illimitée pour vous
faire plein et puis pas payer un kopeck
pendant un an
voilà c'est cadeau aussi ça c'est plutôt
sympa celui qui arrivera en deuxième
classe lui gagnera un stabilisateur faye
ou ak 4500 qui est un gros stabilisateur
qui peut supporter pas mal de poids et
qui est très très bien foutu donc là
pour avoir des plans bien smooth aux
stabilisateurs ça sera royale et enfin
celui qui arrivera à la première place
le grand gagnant lui gagnera le tout
nouveau kit blogueurs de chez nikon dans
lequel il ya un z 50 il ya un socle de
cash small ring il ya aussi un micro
rhodes
il ya un mini trépied manfrotto bien
entendu il ya l'optique qui va avec
voilà tout ce qu'il faut pour soi
démarré en vidéo soit se lancer dans le
blog comme le nom l'indiqué finalement
et ça ça vaut environ 1200 euros donc
voilà tous très très très beaux lots
maintenant comment vous allez faire pour
gagner
c'est l'ol va falloir faire une vidéo
vous le donne en mille
vidéo qui fera moins d'une minute trente
quelque chose d'assez cours tout ce qui
sera au dessus je pourrai
malheureusement pas le prendre et une
vidéo qui aura pour thème le nombre 50
voilà vous pouvez faire ce que vous
voulez du moment que ça tourne autour du
50 comme les cinquante mille abonnés
voilà mes pouvez faire ce que vous
voulez il n'y a pas de limitation du
moment que c'est en lien avec ce thème
là sachant que le critère principal sera
l'histoire que vous allez raconter
racontez moi des histoires cool c'est
pas forcément une histoire de technique
ou de matériel pouvait très bien filmé
au smart phone il ya aucun souci il n'y
a pas besoin d'avoir un matériel
particulier pour participer au concours
cette vidéo vous la mettrais sur youtube
en ont répertorié ou en public comme
vous voulez mais vous me verrez le lien
de votre vidéo à l'adresse mail que j'ai
créée exprès pour le concours qui se
situe juste en dessous de la vidéo que
juste à côté du pouce en l'air que vous
pouvez blast est bien entendu et pour ça
vous avez deux semaine tout pile
à partir d'aujourd'hui après ça je ne
prends plus d'autres vidéos ensuite je
vais pré sélectionné dix vidéos parmi
tout ce que j'aurais reçu puis un jury
composé de gens extraordinaires va se
réunir et déterminer qui seront les sept
gagnants du concours
ce jury sera composé de mike et fabio
les créateurs de la chaîne chronique
fiction d'albert ii soit signer de ar
disque de florian gros frottant de
adelin des copains james de la chaîne
studio sushis et victor boda ainsi que
deux bennes de la chaîne little rock au
funk qui lui est un expert en vidéo aux
smartphones pour vous dire vous pouvez
bien entendu le faire au téléphone le
des gens bien que des gens qui ont
l'oeil
en plus de ça donc ça sera aussi
l'occasion de leur montrer un petit peu
ce que vous savez faire
une fois qu'on aura délibéré je ferai
une vidéo alors ce sera peut-être un
live ce sera peut-être une vidéo normal
je sais pas encore pour annoncer les
grands vainqueurs et puis aussi pour
vous donner un petit coup de pub en
montrant aux vidéos les liens de chaînes
si vous en avez etc etc
donc merci merci merci pour tout j'ai
vraiment hâte de voir un petit peu les
histoires que vous aime raconter de voir
un petit peu ce que vous allez faire
avec cette contrainte avec cette
thématique
et puis les amis rester curieux soyez
créatifs soyez productif faites-moi des
belles vidéos et moi je vous dis à très
très très bientôt pour une nouvelle
vidéo et merci merci merci encore
cinquante mille fois merci j